know I have I haven't actually watched  any of Joe pifer's fights but you know  obviously I'm a fan of the sport so I  know the name I know that you know he  won his Contender series fight he won  his UFC debut so he's doing big things  out there he's also a PA guy like myself  so rooting for him hoping that he  continues to do well and  I mean if we if we match over in the  future he's probably gonna have to win a  lot more fights he's just gonna have to  continue to keep winning and uh you know  for me I'm I'm on my own path if we  cross paths I'll take him out no problem  but uh yeah he's gonna have to continue  to keep winning and proven himself  foreign